For example, let's go take a look at the front page
of our Conference Application. First, let's look at it in Landscape
Mode on a Tablet, now let's look at it on the
phone. See how the layout is different? Let's take a look on
this on the Desktop and see how it adjusts, when you
drag the Window. You can see how the Buttons pop into two
rows when the window gets too narrow to fit all four
comfortably, let's take a look at the magic that makes this happen,
it's actually quite simple. The Menu items are laid out
inside a flex box, and the items inside that flex
box by default are told to take up 46% of
the available space. That means, of course, that only two
items will fit on a line. However, there's an app
media rule that overrides this if there's a minimum width
of the window of 500 pixels. In that case, the
items will each only take up 24% of the space,
so all four items will fit on a single line. Using
Flexbox can be a great way to transform your page. You
can change flex direction or flex order to make dramatic interface
changes like the one I did in the Audio Recorder earlier on.